I've always said we need to take
proportionate action for some people by
the way we've taken too severe action
David others think we're being too
lenient one of the joys of this affair
is they've never been an easy solution
but asking Gary to step back off air was
I think a significant thing and now we
look forward with this agreement moving
forward to resolve things and get back
to business as usual what we've agreed
and I've spent time talking to Gary and
we've had lots of discussion is that
between now and when the review reports
Gary will abide by the editorial
guidelines you said this was your
foundational absolutely issue
impartiality this was a Line in the Sand
it just seems to have been a bit of
disruption to match the day and you just
abandon it if that was just a bit of
disruption to match today then you
probably weren't having the same weekend
I was having I think it was a very big
moment in terms of us saying we have to
take stock here we have to take action
we did take action which we thought was
proportionate
and as the BBC we believe we did the
right thing I think I did the right
thing
having said that I think you have to
look at the balance here and act fairly
and you know there's a lot of people
it's been unfair to Gary lineker there
no I think I've acted in the right way
through this it's always been difficult
as as everyone's been saying on this
affair there's been no easy answers it's
been tough to get the balance right but
asking Gary lineker to step aside I
think was
appropriate at that moment then we reset
and we do the things we've laid out in
this agreement which I think are right
and we go forward